photo merci
il est magnifique judas garde le pour
moi un jour je viens de reprendre
mon maître se meurt il tient à vous
remercier de lui avoir sauvé la vie à
tout ses amis c'est un honneur que des
rencontres et wolverine ce n'est plus ce
que je suis
après guerre l'entreprise familiale est
devenue la plus grande du japon ces
innovations ont sauvé des millions de
vies
j'aimerais offrir un cadeau logan tu as
ces luttes il est temps d'en finir et
pouvoir de guérison peuvent être
transmis est au fardeau à un autre aux
gammes salle je peux te rendre mortels
crois moi mon pote je suis banni exemple
à suivre
je ne suis pas prêt à mourir
vous êtes blessé par être pas
je n'y arrive plus c'est ce qui m'a fait
ça maintenant ça n'est plus qu'un homme
on passe
vous êtes quoi une chimiste capital id
père puis l'avenir c'est ça
c'était du moins
nous acceptons par édition avec respect
c'est tout ce que tu as comme troupes
je suis un rônin pose à moi ils 100 m
il n'a aucune raison de vivre
raison